How about we do this in a spreadsheet. So first let's find the population
standard deviation. We already know that the mean is 2.5. So we'll say, equals
A1 minus 2.5, and we'll square it. So those are the squared deviations. Command
c, command down, command shift up, highlighting these four cells. Command v and
we have all of our squared deviations. Now to take the standard deviation we
take the average of cell B1:B4. So that's the variance. And then we take the
square root of the variance to get the standard deviation. So we get 1.118
approximately. Okay, now let's do the same thing with our sample means. So we
already know that the mean of all our sample means is 2.5. So here we'll write
equals A6 minus 2.5 squared. So we get our first squared deviation. And now
we'll go to that cell, push command c, go to cell A6, command down, go to cell
B21, command shift up, highlighting all these cells and then command v. And now
we get all of our squared deviations, now we'll find the average squared
deviation or the variants. B6 through B21. And then we'll take the square root,
to find the standard deviation. So the standard deviation of our sampling
distribution, or the distribution of sample means, of size n equals 2, is about
0.79. We're going to call this SE.